when Stargate returns will it be a TV
series a movie both
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
do you have a uh oh yeah sorry
if you are a regular side tracker you'll
know that I dropped a bombshell last
week hey hey don't
two figures on either side
praying beside a pyramid with the sun
directly above it as I let you know that
Mark fergus's penguin and Parker is
currently in negotiations to produce
Stargate now I was absolutely blown away
by this news it's the most exciting news
I I really think they're the team that
could do something amazing with Stargate
and I'm just I just love it I was in
front of us the whole time
General West
Jackson has identified the seventh
symbol I also then told you that
actually Mark Fergus didn't just come in
and Pitch Stargate he came in and
created an entire franchise and blew
Amazon Executives away
foreign
but when he produces the first big thing
for Stargate what will it be will it be
a TV series as we expected or will it be
a movie
well eight or nine months ago I told you
actually that a source close to Amazon
had told me plan a for Amazon was always
to produce a movie first now we assumed
back then that meant a movie straight to
Amazon Prime because that's what Amazon
do but that movie would be Cinema
quality well more recently Amazon have
announced that they actually intend to
invest big money over a billion dollars
a year into producing straight to cinema
movies
[Music]
foreign I spoke to my source close to
MGM and he has confirmed to me that
actually ideally that's exactly what
Amazon would like to do
[Music]
don't forget to like subscribe and share
the video with all of your other Gator
friends also you know decideashtrack.com
for brilliant Stargate related merch
just like this you can even buy socks
all the links are in the description now
the fact that they want to go with the
franchise is going to have both movies
and TV series is also another reason why
they decided not to go with Brad Wright
and instead go with a production company
that has some experience in that area
and just go on Mark fergus's IMDb this
man has got some experience and some
really serious projects but this I think
will still be the biggest thing him and
his production company have ever done
[Music]
so why a movie first well at the end of
the day a movie still has a big impact
[Music]
that's what they're looking for they
want to launch the franchise with
something that's going to make people
sit up and notice
the other thing is and this is a harsh
truth to hear but it is the truth Amazon
Don't Care About Us Gators
[Music]
they know that we will watch this now
something simple and easy that they
could do is just get Michael Shanks get
Amanda Tapping maybe get Richard Dean
Anderson to make a guest appearance and
just produce a TV series
thank you
Gators will watch it we will go crazy
and we will love it or hate it
but
they would get us easily
but they don't want to just get Gators
they want to get a much bigger audience
[Music]
and what we want them to get a much
bigger audience because that is the one
way we will get more Stargate
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing
so as a gay to myself I'm really hoping
they produce something that's going to
generate loads of interest and bring in
a new big audience I want everybody that
is fans of Star Trek Star Wars Marvel
even to be excited about this new
project and to watch it because the
bigger the numbers the more Stargate
we'll get and the more money Amazon will
be willing to spend on it
so we will actually not only get
Stargate back on our screens we could
get lots of Stargate back in our screens
with real production value and that's
what we all want but a movie doesn't
just create a big impact and create
interest it also really shows that
Amazon are serious about Stargate so
just imagine for a second we're in the
middle of January we get the
announcement that we're hoping for and
they announced that there's going to be
a Stargate movie and that it's got a
budget of 200 million dollars to produce
that really shows that Amazon are not
only Keen to get Stargate but they are
serious about it and if that does happen
we could get a movie on a screens by
Summer 2024.
we would then get a series that would
follow up that quite quickly it would
really show intent and I actually think
we'll get more than just one serious
announcement I think we could get two or
three series announcements really really
quickly I'll be seeing you around
[Music]
Dr Jackson
foreign
so that's where we are right now it
looks like Mark Fergus has an ambitious
plan he has a big plan he has a
franchise in mind he's created an entire
universe to play with and it looks like
hopefully Amazon are actually going to
back him up with some money and
hopefully he can produce something that
us Gators are going to absolutely adore
but not only your skaters it's going to
draw in a whole new audience a whole new
generation of gators
but guys what do you think get into the
comments do you care whether it's a
movie or a TV series do you or do you
just want Stargate back on our screens
do you care that they are going to have
to bring in a new audience for this TV
show to survive do you understand that
that is just the reality
or are you afraid that this is just
going to be one massive horrible mess
and Amazon are gonna horribly [ __ ] it up
I'd love to know exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you want to fully support the channel
and want to become a side Trekker
yourself consider hitting the join
Button as always please stay safe
it's coming home Gators I'll see you
next time
[Music]